what's up guys helen here to talk about
two provocative filmmakers who share a
last name a deeply twisted sense of
humor and a special place in my already
crowded heart of your little gay here
there's your four dollars your pathetic
piece of [ __ ] that's right the coen
brothers known for their edgy takes on
classic hollywood genres like film noirs
and screwball comedies they infuse
traditional cinematic tropes with their
own unique brand of brutal violence
sharp dialogue and you're studying
all sorts of jolly stuff history
economics same thing isn't it history
economics and an endless cast of weirdly
compelling scumbags but you serve
misfits here yeah daddy that's a roger
but we don't sell alcohol the cullen
brothers distinctive body of work always
has a contemporary tone even when
they're harkening back to decades past
so you might have been surprised to hear
that older brother joel was adapting the
classic shakespearean tale whose title
you can't say in the theater and at
first glance it seems like a perplexing
direction for a guy who cut his teeth in
the likes of blood simple and raising
arizona so why is one half of this
filmmaking duo bringing the most murdery
medieval scottish wannabe royal back to
life examining the way the coen brothers
treat the protagonists in their own
scripts might actually tell us a lot
about why joel connected with the story
of macbeth because if you take a closer
look this guy isn't all that different
from a classic coen brothers protagonist
so join us for this wisecrack edition on
the coen brothers tragedy and or comedy
and spoilers ahead for some coen
brothers films
let's start out by reverse engineering
your typical coen brother's protagonist
in general they're not terribly
successful at least by standard
definitions they're known to encounter
trouble with the law sometimes a lot of
trouble often ineffectual they find
themselves subject to condescension what
is god's holy name are you blathering
about verbal abuse you
eric
you think you're the only writer that
can give me that bought and thing
feeling
i got 20 writers under contract i can
ask for a fig type thing from and even
rejection by their own rabbi what
happened to the [ __ ]
the [ __ ]
who cares they're perpetually bewildered
by the world around them i don't know
which end is up i'm not even sure how to
react i'm too confused and they're often
flying by the seat of their pants while
cosplaying competence this aggression
will not stand man what's more coen
brothers characters are often men with
plans like jerry's plot to have his wife
kidnapped in fargo for some money a hair
brain scheme that ultimately results in
cinema's most creative use of a wood
chipper or hai's knuckle-headed plan to
steal a baby from a wealthy furniture
mogul you go right back up there and get
me a toddler or brad pitt's doomed plot
and burn after reading to sell what he
believes is classified information he
stumbled upon while the coen brothers
have no shortage of humor in their work
i'm pretty sure of the date did i ask
you to sit
no sir but you struck me as a man who
wouldn't want to waste a chair many of
their characters function somewhat as
tragic heroes in the ancient greek mold
as scholar richard gilmour explains in
his analysis of no country for old men
in ancient greece tragedy was considered
a source of wisdom as well as of
entertainment and the primary wisdom was
avoid hubris i.e excessive pride greek
tragedies prominently featured
characters being punished for exhibiting
hubris usually by ancient gods many coen
brothers heroes suffer from hubris their
characters have goals that while not as
grand as becoming king are still vastly
out of step with their actual abilities
in barton fink the titular character
thinks he can bring his deep stories
about the common man to a notoriously
shallow hollywood inside lewin davis
chronicles a small-time folk singer who
doesn't quite have the talent to back up
his big dreams in a serious man larry
wants to learn the full truth about god
and his master plan for the universe a
goal that not even the most gnarled of
rabbis can claim to have achieved be a
good boy what all of these characters
share like many ancient greek tragic
heroes is that sense of hubris in their
approach to their goals whether they're
trying to learn deep religious truths or
simply trying to acquire a baby they
often see themselves as competent heroic
characters on important hero's journeys
the kinds that the greek legends went on
but the cohens let their audience know
in no uncertain terms that these
protagonists are kind of just being
punked importantly the theme of hubris
far from being confined to greek
tragedies and cohen films also permeates
much of shakespeare's work especially
you guessed it macbeth the play charts
the downfall of an ambitious nobleman
who wants to become king and is willing
to do a lot of murder to make that
happen even though his plot works the
consequences pile up and macbeth refuses
to back down and in the process loses
his head like many cohen heroes he's a
man with a plan that he can't quite
manage to see through this makes it
extremely fitting that joel cohen
gravitated towards this particular
shakespearean work it's something of a
medieval iteration of his own
overarching thematic preoccupations the
link of man's hubris becoming his
downfall which we've charted from
ancient greece to shakespeare to the
coen brothers thus makes macbeth seem
all too colony that said characters like
hai and jerry and llewellyn aren't
macbethy into a t the cullen brothers
for the most part aren't just
regurgitating greek myths or
shakespearean downfalls though they may
find inspiration in them they're doing
something distinctly modern taking the
tragic hero in the vein of macbeth and
transforming him to suit our times and
they do so by invoking their jewish
heritage and sculpting many of their
characters into some iteration of the
yiddish folk archetype dishla meal the
schlemiel according to the universal
jewish encyclopedia handles a situation
in the worst possible manner or is
dogged by an ill-luck that is more or
less due to his own ineptness as scholar
ruth whis adds the samil's misfortune is
his character it is not accidental but
essential importantly schlomels have
always had a hand in their own
destruction you know like this guy well
i i was just really trying to elevate
small talk to medium talk that's all i
was doing well don't my marriage is my
business my marriage is fine it has
nothing to do with you we vividly see
this schlemiel-like tendency in many
cohen brothers films from jerry's
foolish kidnapping scheme to llewellyn's
harebrained theft according to scholar
sanford pinsker the chamiel has long
been a source of comic relief in the
distinctive palette of jewish humor
probably since byzantine emperor and
major jerk justinian made anti-semitism
mainstream as pinsker explains although
powerless by conventional standards jews
master the difficult arts of
self-mockery in part through the comic
failures of the shamil pinsker posits
that this brand of humor was a powerful
tool in the jewish people's endless
struggle for survival though the
archetype wasn't popular outside of
jewish communities for most of its
existence whis writes when america as a
whole began to experience itself as a
loser after world war ii and ever more
insistently in the 1950s the chamill was
lifted from his parochial setting into
national prominence
though some scholars see the heyday of
peachla meal being over it still
continued to permeate pop culture
writing about seinfeld in the 90s
scholar carla johnson explains the
show's success in the context of the way
it invokes the chamial trope she says
the point is that jewish experience has
come to mirror the frustrations of
mainstream america the shrinking
opportunities the stalling of the
american dream if that doesn't feel even
more true today than it would have in
the 90s you might just be the owner of
multiple teslas for their part cohen
brothers protagonists are often quite
stuck in their own stalled american
dreams of achieving economic success or
starting a family or launching a career
what's more the schlamealness of the
coen brothers heroes facilitates the
filmmaker's unique approach to melding
comedy and tragedy as ronald emmerich
writes citing sheldon j hirschenow using
the schlemiel creates an ironic
perspective as well as a double vision
both comic and tragic the protagonist
attempts to change their circumstances
are typically much less grandiose than
the likes of the plotting macbeth as a
result their missteps on their path can
be rendered both amusing and kind of sad
indeed each colin brothers protagonist
has aspects of both the tragic and the
comic take their comedic film noir the
big lebowski whose protagonist is the
epitome of the happy stoner still
throughout the film he's constantly
mistreated and emasculated rendering him
a bit tragic what's more his refusal to
back down over the rug precipitates the
death of his friend his character flaw
literally causes him great pain and
misfortune classic schlamel move sad
parts aside though the film functions as
a comedy because the dude accepts his
status in life and doesn't care what
others think he's definitely not
tortured except for that tub scene of
course in contrast one of their most
tragic protagonists larry from a serious
man is unhappy with his lot in life he
has the very not humble goal of wanting
to understand god and truth and
desperately wants to be taken seriously
i've
tried to be a serious man as a result he
has our sympathy and our pity though his
suffering does provide the occasional
chuckle
i seriously
reflect what's going on even so the film
functions basically as a tragedy in this
way the coen brothers use of the
schlemiel can be molded to suit both
comic and tragic characters so long as
their lives are falling apart by
replacing the traditional greek or
shakespearean hero with the schlemiel
the coens update their protagonists to
better suit our time a time when many of
us feel pretty powerless which maybe
also explains why a 74 year old larry
david is still making a super popular
and relevant comedy show evoking this
old trope from yiddish folklore also has
the added benefit of facilitating their
unique mix of farce and tragedy but what
do you guys think is macbeth the natural
next step for a guy like joel cohen does
schlomels make the perfect modern hero
let us know in the comments big thanks
to our patrons for all your support and
don't forget to check out our podcast
hit that subscribe button like you're
smoking a joint before hebrews school
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching
peace
[Music]
you